본인을 너무 사랑한 40대 중년의 은밀한 하루
그렇다 작진 않은 일주일 단기 프로젝트
그렇죠 하지만 강렬한 판매 프로젝트
근데 이거는 사실 판매라기보다는 이익을 보지 않습니다
작년에 이제 우리 애슈라고 화장품 브랜드를 만들었어요
선크림을 출시했었는데 그 선크림 중 일부가 미판매된 채로 이벤트가 종료됐습니다
왜냐면 이제 다른 것들도 있었고 여름이 좀 지났어요
좀 늦게 출시해가지고 물론 여름에만 바르는 건 아니지만
이제 다시 여름이 오고 있으니까 저희가 이거를 감사한 마음을 담아서
여러분들께 선크림을 다시 드리고자
물론 제품은 전혀 문제가 없습니다
애슈 선크림인데 3개에 만원
3개에 만원이요?
3개에 만원입니다 원래 하나가 3만원대인데
3개를 전체 만원
유통기한이 뭐 한 달밖에 안 나온 거다
아니에요 아니에요 선크림 유통기한은 한 2,3년 돼요
그리고 또 하나는 배송비도 없습니다
그래서 선크림 3개가 배송비 없이
배송비가 3개가 배송비 없이
3개가 옵니다 만원에
저희가 어쨌든 이번 영상에서는 선크림을 홍보하는 영상이잖아요
뷰티 인플루언서들 다른 제품들 판매하는 거 보면서 느낀 게
일단 출연자가 이 제품을 쓰는 모습을 잘 보여줘야 돼요
그리고 관리하는 남자 보여주면 이게 확실히 소구가 되더라고요
사실은 피부과 이런 데 다니시면 그냥 발라요
그냥 베이스랑 같이 발라요
피부 노화의 가장 큰 적이 자외선이거든요
우주에서 계속 이 방사선
태양으로부터 소중한 피부를 지키세요
이슈
가끔 진정을 시켜줘야 됩니다
평소에 팩 많이 하시죠
의외로 바르는 게 많습니다
세대주께서 사주신 것도 좀 있고
은행 광고 같지만
마스크팩 붙이고 차트 본 적 있으세요?
있죠
집에서는 이제
회사에서
회사에서?
시키니까 하지
미친놈
정말 미친 가격
이슈
사무실 책상이 진짜 깔끔한 거 같아
왜 그런지 알아요?
알죠?
언제든 나갈 수 있대요
문만 나가면 돼요
애슈 선크림이
애슈 선크림은 혼합자차입니다
선크림 아시겠지만 무기자차가 있고 유기자차가 있어요
유기자차는 화학적으로 자외선을 열로 변환시키는 거고
무기자차는 비화학적으로 막는 거예요
그러다 보면 백탁이 좀 생기게 하게 돼요
이거는 백탁도 없이 혼합자차로
그래서 발라보시면
오 그러네요
백탁이 없네요
백탁이 거의 없어요
계속 바르면 로션 느낌 나요
여름에 이거 바르고 나가는 거예요
그다음에 이거 바르고 나가는 그냥 로션 바르는 느낌이에요
남자분들이 여기 바르고 손바닥에 바르고 이렇게 바르거든요
그러면 안 돼요 원래는
이렇게 이렇게 이렇게 바르더라고
남성들 바르는 거 비비
상무님 비비 바르세요?
비비는 비비는 잘 안 발라요
오늘 그 애겠나 말썽 가서 바른다고
아 그렇구나 비비 조금 발라요
비비 바르기 전 애슈 선크림
젤리 토마토 하나고요
구운 가지 이거하고
콩모시 오일 링기네 하나고요
엔초비도 주시고요
생선 스테이크도 주시고요
진짜 미러킹의 뷰티미 콜러스테이크
진짜로 꾸덕하지도 않고
그리고 향이 되게 좋아요
기분 좋은 향이다
진짜 향 좋다
그렇죠 강하지도 않고
선크림 아침에도 바르고 나왔는데
수분감이라고 해야 되나
그렇죠
되게 잘 발리는 것 같아요
그렇죠 흡수가 잘 되죠
막 먹어요 그냥
오늘 여기 베스트는 이 생선 요리가 아닌가
진짜 맛있다
내가 찍어야겠다 이 불쌍한 친구들
너무 선해
점심에 이런 거 안 먹어봐요
못 먹어
살짝 우리 그거 같다
미군 용병이 던져준 초코빵이 그거 같네
코리아 선크림 베리 굿
상무님 햇빛이 너무 센 거 같아요
햇빛이 너무 세서 많이 발라줘요
시간마다 발라줘야 하고 선크림이
왜냐면 이게 녹아서
그니까요
미국 가도 사라지고 땀 때문에
혼자 오셨나 봐요 해가 너무
이제 따가워져서 맨 얼굴로 앉아계시면 안 돼요
발라드릴게요
발림성 엄청 좋죠
봐봐 이거 벌써 탔잖아
혼합 자차고 엄청 좋아해요
여기 앉아 계실 때는 꼭 바르세요 알았죠
특별히 만난 것도 기념이니까
이거 드리고 갈 테니까 알았죠
뽀 바르시고
아 이거 또 어디 또 바를 데가 없나
발라줄 데가 없나
소중한 것을 지키는 나만의 방법
애슈 선크림 3개의 만화 한정 판매 중
좋아 이번엔
이걸 보고 안 웃었으면 정말 최악입니다